Voilà, y a même plus de place pour les bergers
sur les estives. Aujourd'hui,
C'est quoi les plus loin sur le loup.
Et je pense qu'il faut quelque chose de simple
quand on dit qu'on doit simplifier les choses,
c'est-à-dire, euh,
s'il faut plus que 2 formulaires au lieu de 6,
avant de tirer sur 1 loup qui attaque 1 troupeau,
oui, on a simplifié, hein.
Avec ça, on est avec ça,
avec ça, on est bien parti, non ?
Je pense qu'il y a 1 moment
il faut des choses évidentes,
de bon sens.
Quand vous avez 1 loup qui arrive pour attaquer 1
bah le berger ne pourra tirer dessus. Pour, pour,
pour, pour. On tire d'abord et on fait le papier après.
Oui, bien sûr, mais rassurez-vous, normalement, euh,
le loup n'a pas ces notions-là.
Et je pense que quand il approche d'un troupeau,
c'est pour bouffer les moutons